What are your thoughts about supplemented with N-M-N?
So N-M-N is nicotinamide model nucleotide to a supplement that is a precursor for N-A-D.
So N-A-D is a really hacked supplement in the supplement business right now.
N-A-D does is it increases ATP by stimulating and increasing the metabolic pathways.
It is, oh, as Angie types in, Leo, her dog diagnosed two years ago, still going strong using the right for N-A-D.
So I am not a fan of using N-A-D with cancer.
So it stimulates the metabolic pathway, it stimulates growth pathways.
It can be really good for people that are working out and try to build muscle and try to
have more stamina in their workouts. But with somebody with cancer, no, I'm not a fan of using any N-A-D
stimulants for that reason. That's something that could increase growth factors and increase
the rate of replication of cells which is, could be really great if you don't have cancer,
right? But if you have cancer, then it can have issues. Even if you don't have cancer,
you have to be careful with some of these supplements. N-A-D, I know people that have used N-A-D
and, oh, you know, well, if something is good, then three must be better.
That could increase heart rate and can give a person a tachycardia.
So you have to be careful with some of these things even if you're in a state of really good health.
But I would not use N-A-D or cancer for some.